[Music]
good morning Hank good morning Hank it's
Tuesday
it's Tuesday Hank good morning it's
Tuesday it's 11:40 in the morning good
morning say hello to the nerdfighters
guys greetings got Lester Feld's peeps
what you think it's been grossing vibe
very good it's good right yeah say hello
to the nerdfighters hello nerdfighters
give them some of your wisdom the only
problems worth solving are solutions
it seems to me that that's one of those
things that sounds profound until you
actually break it down and it means
nothing I think the only solutions worth
having our problems Hank I want to say
thanks again to you and all of the
nerdfighters for everything that y'all
did for my birthday I had a great
birthday but more than that all of those
videos and pictures and songs they
helped rejuvenate my awesome which is
really important right now because I'm
working like mad on Paper Towns I've
only got a couple weeks left before I'm
going to turn it in and it's because I'm
so grateful to you for restoring my
awesome levels that I'm not getting mad
at you for the fact that you don't get
up until 2 o'clock in the afternoon
thank you like a raccoon actually I
think right now you are awake you're
just eco geeking thanks speaking of eco
geeking everyone in my pants wants to
know what the difference between a nerd
and a geek is I don't really know the
answer to that question but I'm hoping
that together with the help of the
nerdfighters we can figure one out ok
Hank I just talked to mom and she said
that she's kind of upset that yesterday
dad got to be in a video so now she
wants to be in a video
so here's mom you're on Brotherhood 2.0
that's pretty funding yes
no women we're incredibly famous what
are you talking about what are you
laughing at Katherine very famous you
know I keep saying to people
you know young people I mean in the
airport or well walking down the street
I asked them you know if they know
anything about nerdfighters and you know
what they always tell me and that's what
they always ha ha ha but I keep hoping
I keep plugging away waiting for a
nerdfighter to you know give me the sign
that they go with her Viterbo's can you
show me the sign can you do it
nerdfighters that was awesome okay go
away now mom is such a nerdfighter Hank
I'll see you tomorrow
well actually I'll see you when I walk
down the hall but I mean I'll see you on
YouTube tomorrow